up next star talk special edition I've
got Chuck nice I've got Gary O'Reilly
and our geek and chief Charles Lou to
help us decode some of the deepest
questions asked by our patreon members
including for example uh are there any
questions that astrophysicists think
about that we don't have an answer to
yet what what's up with that
also where is are the terrestrials
extraterrestrials having conversations
with each other can we decode it is
there some
special uh encryption that they're using
that we will never know how to break
into it we're going to learn about that
also a little bit about Quantum field
Theory what is it why does it matter
coming up on Star
[Music]
Talk this is Star Talk special edition
we got Chuck Nice Chuck yes hey hey
what's rally I knew all right and we're
doing Cosmic query's grab bag and I
think I'm okay with a grab bag but
generally we need bigger guns than that
so we went into the silo typed in the
launch codes and out came Charles Lou
how you doing dude hi Neil hi everybody
welcome back to Star talk thank you you
know I'm unworthy I can get him get him
to the get him near the edge you could
take us off the edge and take us into
orbit and that's what we need you for in
these situations we got questions from
our patreon members so this is grabag so
we what do you guys have what did you
bring to the table today all right let
me jump in first Thomas Cochran uh from
Kansas City are we thinking about the
fundamental SL basic components of the
universe
incorrectly perhaps the universe's most
basic building blocks are Fields instead
of particles what Merit does Quantum
field Theory have and there's already a
thank you tagged on the end oh that's so
nice well the bottom line is you're both
right whether you're thinking in
particles or in fields in fact Quantum
field theory is in fact trying to knit
together quantum mechanics special
relativity and classical field Theory
right field theory is what it's it's
pretty straightforward we as particles
interact with Fields such as a
gravitational potential field of the
Earth
or some electromagnetic field something
like that so different kinds of objects
depending on their properties interact
in different ways with different fields
now if you think instead that we as
particles are actually not
static things solid things or whatever
but are rather waves or Fields but in
sort of strange unusual concept then you
can just m mathematically Express every
particle in our bodies as a field
interacting with a larger field or with
other kinds of fields maybe the higs
field the thing that provides Mass so
we're not looking at it wrong so much as
we're looking at it in an incomplete
fashion right one of the big things
about the universe right Neil is that uh
we still can't knit general relativity
and quantum mechanics together so people
are using different approaches to try to
get at the same answer and it's totally
okay if you're not able to address
everything with your theory as long as
somebody else is addressing the other
stuff with another theory maybe we can
bring them all together yeah I would add
a Nuance to that that it's not that
there are Fields And there are particles
and never the twain may meet it is the
very interaction of fields and particles
that is the universe that is what what
that is the operations of the universe
so one of those would not be more
fundamental than the other when they
need each other to manifest the universe
as we have come to know and love now we
might say something else you might say
is there something more fundamental than
both the field and the particle and and
Charles would string theorists jump into
this at this point they might claim yeah
particle if the claim is that a particle
is just a manifestation in our SpaceTime
of what we see of a more complex object
then the interactions of strings to some
extent might either supplant or
supersede interactions between fields or
interactions between particles right
right right so that would be a deeper
understanding but we're not choosing
particles versus Fields right no they're
both working together very nicely that's
right worlds are
colliding cats and dogs are sleeping
together yeah that does happen that is a
Bible verse isn't it that's the one of
the signs of the Apocalypse right so
who's next up how about Brandon
cazar look at that and Brandon says
hello Neil hello Charles this is Brandon
from Scranton PA my question to both hi
BR yeah uh say hello to the people at
Dunder Mifflin my question to you both
is what is the one thing that is
currently unknown in the science and
astronomy world that you wish to find
the answer to before your time on this
Earth comes to an end o
why so why so ominous with the way that
I I I had no other choice you changed
that voice to make it sound like to an
end the words required him to say it
exactly the way he did they did you know
I mean we we are speaking of your
ultimate
demise no Chuck it your ultimate demise
you
know doesn't weigh the same right
exactly well uh Neil you have one I I
know one I got lot a second okay the one
I want to know I would like to know is
does life exist outside of our solar
system outside of our Earth that's based
on DNA I imagine based on all the
scientific knowledge there is life out
there and when people ask me do you
think they're aliens I say yes but the
question is would we recognize them if
we see them would they have developed
the same way that we do so my question
is pretty specific because because
Brandon asked about being scientific
right I got to narrow it down instead of
just saying is there alien life but is
there alien life based on DNA that's
what I how Prometheus of you it is it is
but wait Charles what you really mean is
not is it based on DNA you you have the
broader question is because that's just
a yes no the question is if there is
alien life on what system of chemistry
does it base its identity that's be it
DNA or anything else sure that would be
the extension of my question yeah yeah
okay right but if it if it is based on
the DNA which we find in all human life
and sorry in all life on this planet all
life on this planet okay we share that
DNA then that would mean most likely
that we came from someplace else it
could mean that but it wouldn't have to
I'll tell you why it wouldn't have to
wouldn't have to but but it but it'd be
a very uh likely um scenario that we
came no no all you have to do is look at
the Strand look deep in the strand of
DNA see if it matches anything here it
doesn't match anything it's a complete
separate genis separate right correct
correct right but if there are markers
that match no that means that we share
something that's out there and and
Charles isn't it true in Star Trek that
they finally fessed up season seven
season seven Star Trek the Next
Generation the episode called the chase
damn that's crazy John's old
anthropology Professor figures out that
there's something really cool but
unfortunately he dies before he can find
the answer so the car takes the
Enterprise all around and they find out
indeed that the reason all the Klingons
and all the romulans and all the Lans
and all the humans have two arms two
legs and one head is because they share
a common
ancestor so we don't don't sh is this
your first race War come
on so what if what if this isn't a a DNA
commonality here and you know you have
you end up with ferm's Paradox and we're
we're look where are they all that that
we're just not looking in the right way
they've turned up and they're all gas
based and and this is why I think that
Neil's extension of my question Mak
sense if we are wise enough or or
insightful enough to look for life in
ways that we don't have it here on Earth
we may find it much more quickly than we
think or you can take sort of the Edward
Snowden idea and think that any
intelligent uh species out there will do
its best to hide its presence from
anybody else so as to protect that
privacy oh they sh okay yes and there's
Star Trek next Generation episode about
that too where the Enterprise goes into
an environment for a bunch of very shy
aliens and they usually find a way to
sort of push the anyone who comes in
away but the Enterprise is too good they
show up and so they wind up having to
interact with the aliens and then they
have well there's one where they
literally push the Enterprise away with
a Repulsor beam oh as they approach the
planet but yeah all right well actually
there's a branch of the military that
concerns itself with this there's an
interesting phenomenon so if I send you
a
signal and you decode it I don't want
you to decode it right so the fact that
you know it's a signal is because it
looks different from everything else
that you're otherwise coming to your
detector okay so what I want to do is
encode it so that you can't figure out
what's in it and the perfect encoding of
my signal is where when you receive the
signal it looks completely like noise
because if there's any lingering
structure to it then you hand it over to
the cryptographers and then they decode
the structure and they'll find the
message within it the the argument then
is the most sophisticated forms of
communication will be indistinguishable
from noise from just from just and the
civilization will just disappear into
the D of the background and you will
never know what anybody's saying ever
again that's a limiting case of inco of
encrypted messaging just what I put it
out just blasted with a bunch of static
why waste your time doing that but
because your signal would still be
visible within it unless your signal was
encrypted to look like static
correct yeah it is W So my answer to
that question
is I want to
know if it's a two-part question I want
to know if we are smart enough to even
answer the question questions we have
posed or better yet damn are we smart
enough to even know what questions to
ask right that's the I want the answers
to those two
questions we're still asking them aren't
we but this is this where AI comes in
Neil where we set it up to ask for the
things that we haven't thought to ask
for to look for the things we haven't
yet thought to look for okay that'd be
great put put it to work immediately
because I can tell you this a chimp will
not know to ask can the rotation rate of
Earth slow because an earthquake changed
the moment of inertia of the rotating
sphere not even bubbles could ask that
bubbles I think bubbles know NE I mean
just think a question that is so removed
that they don't even know that's a
question so I want to know are there
those kinds of questions we could be
asking about the universe and we're not
even there yet and even if we're there
will we know to ask the question that's
the question I want answer let's ask
bubbles of
[Laughter]
Jim all right next question keep it com
those are great answers go ahead um
we've got bill wle or wasel wesel number
of ways you can pronounce this uh he's
from Tas probably only one I'm betting I
know but he he even admits we'll
probably get it wrong since time travel
causes Mass to disappear in one space
time and appear in another wouldn't that
require a mass to energy conversion in
the in the original space time and an
energy to mass conversion in the
destination and wouldn't that
essentially be a huge nuclear bomb or
reverse okay well let me see if I
understand the correction correctly I'm
I'm going to I was I was about to say I
don't get what he's asking I'm gonna
answer question before before you answer
Charles so so Gary look me in I okay
repeat after me
nuclear nuclear thank you not nuclear
nuclear nulear thank you for the
correction nuclear you're not George W
bush nuc thank you for that thank you
for that distinction okay on this show
it's nuclear okay go Charles So to avoid
a nuclear explosion the way that we
would solve this
problem that's the worst much
appreciated that's the worst kind of
exposion you pronounce nuclear however
you want you'll still be part of the
nuclear family of Star Talk oh hilarious
all right here's the
story I assuming that what the question
is asking is time travel backwards and
in a large jump like say from here now
to Jurassic times or to the sinking of a
Titanic or something like that right
because we are always moving through
time anyway when I am here and then an
hour from now I move down the street you
know to get an ice cream cone or
something like that uh then what will
happen is that I have just moved in
space and time right and there was no
nuclear explosion so the question I
think is being asked is is there a
scenario where if you're moving not the
way we ordinarily move through SpaceTime
would that cause a contradiction and
some sort of huge energy release because
Mass has been displaced and there's
equals MC squ things like that and you
sure the question isn't really your mass
changes as you move fast so are you
getting that Mass from some other place
is that getting converted out of some
form of energy or vice versa could be
the question could be the question too
sure anyway yeah the bottom line is a
great question but we're not exactly
sure what the answer is because there
are ways to interpret that question
bottom line is I would say that
generally speaking time travel forwards
you know which was what we do and
occasionally backwards like what
antimatter particles do does not
necessarily have to cause a an equals MC
s like release of energy you can do it
in other ways girl did you just say
animat moves backwards in time you just
said that didn't you I did say that you
could think of antimatter as as
backwards travel okay's he's doing a
he's doing the Eno fery thing on us here
am I correct no correct WR you're
correct yeah you're correct you're
correct it was it was disco part of the
the discovery thinking that led to the
prediction for
antimatter was antimatter would be
indistinguishable from regular matter
but moving backwards through
time and then they figured well
everything's moving forward through time
so maybe it's a new kind of matter
called antimatter so that's how that
came
about okay give me some more this is
anthropocosmic Dylan he says Neil in
Cosmic queries you make the distinction
between intelligence and life other than
the common ways we transmit messages
like radio and light could we be
bombarded with measurable or tangible
transmissions and just not know it
thanks Dylan from San Diego yeah that
relates to what we just said a moment
ago said that yeah I mean we just talked
about that if the civilization wants to
be
noticed their signal should look
different from the background noise of
the universe otherwise how could they
could expect us to pick it up right I
would assume they're smart enough to
arrive at that conclusion but if they
wanted to talk about us without us
knowing which would be the alien
equivalent of pig latin in front of
children okay
or or some you know way that you do that
they would they would as we said earlier
they would encode their message you need
a key and with that key it would be able
to decode complete noise into the signal
that you put there but the real issue
because it's there's an issue here real
issue is how did they get the key in the
first
place how
you yeah I'm gonna say the key is Pig
Latin would wouldn't it be funny if they
just sent us a message in pig
latin Al y AR y oo yay or ubby duby ubby
there's a great
Oneil do we need AI to to build us a
21st century Enigma machine yes and
we'll get back to that when we return
from this first break in Star Talk
special edition we'll be right
back we're back Star Talk segment
two special edition with our geek and
chief Charles Lou cuz like I said we
pull them out of The Silo the the the
garage I do not wait in a silo for you
by the way I I hang out on my uh four
poster feather bed in my uh okay top
level Resort hanging out taking it easy
he is our InterContinental geek missile
waiting to be launched from our Silo
exactly exactly hang out with the corn
and wheat so uh what what kind of
question oh so so Gary you you threw in
AI at the end there I think AI will do
things that we don't know how to we
can't figure out how to do by the way
Charles and I as astrophysicists have
been invoking the Brilliance of
computers from the beginning and not
just doing rote tasks but have it do
tasks where it's going to discover stuff
that we would glaze over if we had to
review that much data or just find
things that are weird or wacky so uh now
we can get it to try to decode or to
invent a code that could be sent sure
hey you know we don't fear AI the way
everybody else is right now that's right
okay guys you guys are going to destroy
us all I see I see how it works I
already know the name of our robot
overlords yeah but Charles I don't want
to speak for you but I think we're we've
been using the powers of computer ever
from the beginning and all of a sudden a
computer can now compose your ter paper
and everyone loses their because it
stepped into the world of of of of of
the liberal arts those turn pap are like
C+ B minus at best I wouldn't I'd agree
if you're really if you really no may
they may get better in my most recent
final exam I had for my students the
following question type the following
question into an artificial intelligence
language generator and now tell me what
the answer is wrong
about interesting so you trick these
people in the using AI they're like damn
this guy won't even let us
cheat it's a matter of it's a matter of
them understanding what you need to know
today right if we can't be better than
some free app you can get on the
internet then what is your value to an
organization or to a graduate program or
to a company right so you should learn
how to use them see their weaknesses and
use your education and your thought
processes to make you more valuable and
that's how we must move forward in all
of Education if we teach people exactly
the same way we
you know unun a lot of we do with math
and science right what are we giving
them what is theage that they're getting
from their wait Chuck Gary Gary I think
Charles Lou is the overlord I'm gonna
say so keep going all right okay next up
Nathan Hill right Nathan Hill is from
Austin Texas and he did go to your
Cosmic perspective perspective talk as
well as the Q&A when you were down there
near I was there yes yes I I gave talk
yes my question is regarding gravitons
If gravity is an effect of mass warping
space time where does the need for a
graviton fit into the relativistic model
oh I'll give my best answer you fix it
up okay so if you have a piece of mass
sitting there in space there's the
Distortion of space and time okay there
it is it's a it's a it's the fabric
responding to the existence of the mass
now you poke them Mass you either
Collide two black holes you Jiggle It
you you shake and bake it and a ripple
gets sent that Ripple moves at the speed
of light and the quantum analog to that
Ripple is a graviton moving at the speed
of light and so but the fabric shape
itself is not the graviton that's my
understanding of this Charles I think
you said it exactly correct uh the
another way to think about it is the
following the graviton is a particle
that's been proposed but never been
detected and the reason it was proposed
is because we want to try to fit gravity
into quantum physics right the theory of
relativity that Einstein came up with
did not have in it this idea that you
had to had a particle transmitting
graving but once we built quantum theory
and Quantum field Theory and all those
kinds of things and we got the sense
that in order for any one particle to
interact with any other particle a third
particle has to mediate the transfer of
something between those two this is the
field Theory that's right and so people
said well if gravity is indeed a field
that generates force and there must be a
particle that transmits that Force let's
call it the graviton but it doesn't fit
well in the current standard model of
political physics in fact you don't need
the graviton to do any of those things
with quirks and fans and bons and and
all those kinds of neat things so at the
moment gravitons remain a mystery and
they're a placeholder for some more
sophisticated physical theories that we
don't have yet that will link quantum
mechanics with general relativity we
have nonetheless detected gravitational
waves so that's a very Nobel Prize all
around for that that's right and so yeah
numerous people do think that the
gravitational waves are essentially an
indirect confirmation of the existence
of gravitons yeah but I don't know yeah
so basically what you're saying is we've
rebuilt the engine and we've got this
other stuff left on the
side but we know it's pull somewhere but
we can't quite work out where it has to
go in the thing then you start the
engine and then your car blows up then
you know oops that should have gone but
oddly that doesn't happen that's the
weird thing about it I know everybody I
know who's rebuilt in engine there's
always some parts
just it's it's the universe's uh
equivalent of an Ikea like Furniture
that's right why do I have this extra
Allen Wren what is that why is all this
stuff left over but you know it works
the chair works it works it works it
works all right this is Johnny and
that's all he says uh but Johnny says
hello Charles hello Neil in a prior
episode Neil mentioned that Hawking
radiation process uh occurs due to the
intense gravitational energy directly
around the Event Horizon it is it really
because of the curvature that it's so
intense that it manifests into actual
energy or is it just the energy of stuff
it's sucking in I have always thought
that gravity was just merely potential
energy and then he signs it Bill Bailey
uh so you know Johnny is Bill Bailey
apparently won't you come home Bill
Bailey won you come home look at you
that's a whole that's a whole that's a
whole that's a song that's a song that's
a song baby yeah that's a song so so
there's a lot to unpack in that question
let me let me hand to Charles so tell us
the difference between just the
gravitational field and and what we
think of as gravitational energy and
then energy density just unpack all that
for us it gets it gets a little bit in
the weeds but fundamentally if you have
a field and you have a particle in that
field that interacts with the field
there's a little bit of energy when you
move that particle in the field it feels
a force and some sort of energy gets
released depending on where you are in
the field the amount of energy released
varies hence the concept of energy
density over here you're going to have
more energy per Cub centimeter Orum
something like that over there you have
fewer okay so when you're talking about
Hawking radiation in a black hole
there's actually a lot that still needs
to be straightened out all right now
what Hawking was doing was doing a
Quantum SL thermodynamic argument about
any object that's in the universe that's
Compact and it's got some sort of Event
Horizon okay but really you can take
those equations and extend them and you
can say that pretty much
anything exerts pretty much anything
emits something along the lines of
Hawking radiation it's just that for
black holes uh it's actually important
because that amount of emission is the
only stuff that's coming away from the
Event Horizon of the black hole right
the rest of the stuff is all outside the
Event Horizon that's doing any kind of
emission of energy so that's why Hawking
radiation is cool at the moment we don't
know if it's because of you know some
sort of uh say effect that you have
antimatter matter pairs near the Event
Horizon and we don't know if it's
Quantum tunneling we don't know if it's
just some sort of basic thermodynamic
effect that happens in all cases so
there's still mystery there so you put
your finger on a good question that yet
needs to be answered did I tell you what
Brian Green told me recently I had lunch
with him Brian Green up the street here
at Columbia University the elegant
Universe author of The Elegant universe
and several other books to follow so he
told me that there's emergent thinking
that this vacuum energy of virtual
particles that pop in and out of
existence and these particles are are
matter and antimatter pairs that energy
creates and then they refind each other
and then they become energy again which
is a vacuum version of what Hawking
radiation is right outside of a out
right outside of a black hole he was
suggesting that when they are created
and separated they're Quantum and
Tangled yes and while they are quantum
entangled the actual connection between
them is a
wormhole which is how you can have
information move basically instantly
okay or or or the state be resolved
instantly because it's an actual
Wormhole and what he said was that the
very stitches of SpaceTime might be this
my network of wormholes
created by virtual particles coming in
and out of existence wow so it's not
just metaphor that the SpaceTime is a
fabric it it's like it is a fabric and
the wormholes is the material that
weaves the fabric of space and time that
freaked me out I indigest that's really
cool man yeah well the virtual particles
Wink in and out of existence in tiny
fractions of a second so they have to
keep replenishing some all the time if
that's the fabric of SpaceTime otherwise
the fabric of SpaceTime just falls apart
like the tapestry that's been hanging
for too long oh oh oh dear oh dear
renovation in the castle the
castle it's you know the end the end of
uh this guy's question the end of
Johnny's question he says and I always
thought gravity was merely potential
energy right but surely that can't be
the case in space because there's no up
no down it's not like to take it up so
as it drops down and I've got potential
energy gravity is not potential energy
but gravity if you have a particle
that's in a gravitational field and that
particle has mass it contains
gravitational potential energy which can
then be released if it falls through the
system to be clear particle not there if
the particle's not there we still use
the phrase It's a gravitational
potential okay potential well you get
put the particle here then it has
gravitational potential energy I just
want to put
you're exactly right and so in space we
don't worry about up or down Gary as you
rightly say we worry about whether it's
in or out or out right if it's close to
or away from yes some sort of
gravitational Center exactly yeah yeah
cool all good wow all good flip one more
in before our second break all right
Brian Ridge doesn't say where he's from
uh instead of dark energy within the
known universe is there a chance
something Beyond is sucking to cause the
expansion of the Universe from Beyond if
it was traveling away at the speed of
light we would never witness it right
question mark yeah so so Charles does
the does the universe
sucky the universe does not suck okay
thank you thank you okay and neither do
black holes but that's another
conversation I was going to say which
universe doesn't suck you ask that the
other Universe yeah there's so many of
them Charles I mean come on that's true
no the question is whether Another
Universe is creating this anti-gravity
suction is is somehow causing the
expansion right in other in order for
that to happen there are two assumptions
you can make and it depends right
assumption number one is if that were
the case then that means that our
observable universe is just a little
bubble in a much larger universe and
something around the outside can
therefore create that kind of expansion
through suction right but that that
hasn't been confirmed yet there are
ideas for example something called
Eternal inflation which suggests that
that might be a way that Multiverse is
created but there's nothing that we know
of uh in terms of the mechanics of the
cosmology that we understand that could
cause that in that scenario the other
situation might be that if we as A
four-dimensional Spacetime were embedded
in a five-dimensional membrane oh then
that Fifth Dimension and not talking you
know Motown right but that Fifth
Dimension well then you could imagine
although we again haven't figured out
anything physical yet that could be this
you could imagine that our
four-dimensional thing is expanding in
the fifth dimensional thing almost
because of something say a surface
tension in the same way that say an oil
slick expands across across the surface
of the water surface of the water when
the water it just keeps expanding no
matter what that's right and so you have
a situation where we're trying to figure
out the mathema aspects of how you might
connect four-dimensional spacetimes
within five dimensional membranes but
there's nothing physical yet that allows
that to happen so so now the answer I
guess to the question is stay tuned yeah
okay so if it's surface tension
Charles could we not use that to travel
like a pwn skater across the surface of
a pwn if it is some kind of surface
tension that would be an awesome way to
travel in The Fifth Dimension there you
go and then then you could violate the
you know this faster than but that's
because you're yes but that's because
you're not in our four-dimensional
SpaceTime anymore right the laws of
speed limits and physics or whatever
Mass Etc could be completely different
which is for example one of the tenants
of something called Randall sundrum
Theory where Dr Rand Dr Randall sundrum
Theory okay okay Balera sundrum and Lisa
Randall they came up with this idea some
years ago suggesting that if indeed our
SpaceTime were connected to other
four-dimensional space time via
membranes that might explain things like
why gravity is so much weaker on same
distance scales as the nuclear force
right why is that the case these are the
things that we don't know yet but
they're they're being thought about and
that's kind of gravity is is
embarrassingly weak right all the rest
of this yeah well yes gravity is
ridiculously weak but because it can
extend over long distances and because
it does not have a negative that cancels
out the positive gravity in the universe
on Cosmic scales has no equal yeah I may
be weak but I'll beat your ass in the
day come on with it what you want to do
I'm
gravity yeah that is the exact voice
gravity would have I'm sure try me try
me you know who I am you all know I'm
gravity we got to take a break we come
back for Segment three of Star Talk
special edition
return we're back for the third and
final segment of Star Talk special
edition we got Cosmic queries going here
with Chuck knce we got Gary Riley and
our geek and chief Charles Lou so
intercontinental
ballistic we we we we we open up the The
Silo with the right launch codes out
came Charles Lou because he however
geeky I am he yes he goes
beyond down a veritable Hellfire of
knowledge upon you
all I will gladly deliver whatever
payload I can there you go right so what
who's who's teed up next okay let's jump
straight in Joe stamps that's with an S
if you move backwards from a giant
ticking clock at the speed of light what
does it do stop ticking because because
of the relativity or because the light
from the next second can never reach you
thanks for all you do and respect from
me and my family who keep looking up oh
excellent that's so cool yeah well yeah
the answer is actually they're both
right relativity allows you to think of
time and space in different ways because
they are relative to one another they
behave different so you do not see that
clock tick because you are moving away
from it at the speed of light and so the
sound or the information from the tick
never reaches you it will still tick in
its own stationary frame of reference
but you will never know that it ever
happened so in that sense you could say
the clock ticks but it doesn't tick for
you not for whom the clock ticks but for
whom the clock tolls yeah okay so but
but if there's another clock that you're
headed towards right then you would see
that clock go faster because you're
catching up with every next tick correct
that's right that's right so it's the
the direction you're travel of reference
and the speed it's all about frame yeah
frame of reference that's what makes the
whole thing work nice nice all right
let's keep going cool okay how about
Alexandria French Alexandria French she
says my husband and I listen while we
cook dinner every night nice what are
you cooking what you cooking yeah and
thanks for sending us
no I know right right yeah exactly it's
French food it's French good yeah we'll
have a little C saying we'll take it uh
let's see she says uh I have a burning
question that came from uh that I came
from patreon to ask if we could put a t
the question Burns there's there's an
ointment for that I
Think Jesus
chist hope it doesn't burn while you're
cooking don't burn your don't burn your
food okay if we could put a telescope on
a Galaxy say 15 million light years away
with the depth of the observable
universe Chang based on the changing the
point of the
observation love it thank you well uh
the
answer Alexandria and husband um I would
say is that no it does not change 15
million light years away Alexandria
is actually the center of that spots
observable universe 15 million 15
billion wherever you are away from us
that is the center of the observable
universe at that point you see uh we are
living in a universe that expanded from
a single point which means that you
can't actually point to one spot in our
current universe and say that one is the
center any more than you can point to
any other place and say it's the center
so every spot in the universe is
expanding away from every other spot and
therefore we have a infinite number of
centers of observable universes because
every single spot is the center in its
own observable universe but Charles I
got to add if there if there's a Galaxy
at the edge of the universe which is on
the edge of our observable universe and
we go there m that Galaxy will see just
as far on the other side yes of its
location and it'll see half the universe
that we cannot see correct because so
it's in the center of its own Horizon so
I my thought the question was what will
they see relative to us if you go if you
go to the Horizon they'll see parts of
the universe we can't see but they still
think they're in the middle of the known
universe right it's like being it's like
being out in the middle of the ocean and
spotting an island you're like you know
Land Ho but from from on the other side
of that Island they may be looking out
at stuff that you won't be able to see
as you look at that island but the
island was On Your Horizon right the
island was On Your Horizon yes right
right right okay I think that's where
that was coming from I think sounds good
yeah okay right Gary what do you got all
right Christopher Scott's next up given
that energy is neither created nor
destroyed does this mean that all of the
fossil fuels that are in the ground as
forms of stored energy have been around
for eons already
if so are we simply redistributing the
location of the energy on our Tiny
Little Rock in space we are not actually
adding any more energy to the system
just moving where it is can I take can I
answer this can I
answer don't get where the okay go ahead
okay you ready okay all so first of all
energy can be destroyed by turning it
into matter okay so it's so so the the
concept of energy can neither be created
or destroyed was modified after equals
mc² and it's the sum of energy and
matter that cannot be created or
destroyed it's the sum of those two okay
so now the fossil
fuels are solar
energy all those life forms got their
energy from the Sun if they were plant
life they got it directly if they were
animal life they got it because they ate
the plants that got the sunlight so
fossil
fuels is solar
power except that it's polluting the air
and it's we're not going to be able to
reproduce it because all that energy was
came and been sitting there for us for
millions of years it's been buried
energy once we use it and it radiates
out into space it goes back into the
universe it's not still here on Earth
Charles you take it over from there
what else can I add what a beautiful
explanation you add the fact that the
energy that it is creating is a
perturbation of the atmospheric
conditions that create global warming
and that creates more energy or actually
intensifies energy and it's part of it's
going to destroy us all yeah we trap
more sunlight we trap more sunlight
becomes a giant magnifying glass
releasing the solar energy precisely
Gary releasing the solar energy that was
stored in these microorganisms which
were turned into coal and oil and
natural gas or whatever these fossil
fuels are uh also releases at the same
time how it got bound down underneath
the Earth which in this case is carbon
carbon and the carbon comes out in the
form of carbon dioxide and it is adding
something new to our atmosphere
atmosphere that we haven't seen in in
hundreds of thousands of years so the
answer is that if you define the system
as the universe including the Sun and
deep down in the earth and Out In Space
the energy has not been created or it's
been redistributed but if you're
thinking about the system as our Earth's
atmosphere our biosphere the environment
that humans live in oh yes we are
injecting a lot of lot of energy we are
adding a huge amount and it's not just a
balance chain it's an actual increase
and by all the different features that
everybody here has said so far so yes of
course the difference is the original
source of energy was the sun it came to
Earth was stored and locked underground
now we have re-released that energy uh
where after we've created civilization
on a stable relatively stable climate
and now we are altering the climate by
re-releasing this Pandora's box of
energy right well in primarily because
of the byproduct of it which is the
burning of fossil fuels which is where
you get your CO2 there you go there you
go guys we got time for one more
question give it to me go ahead Gary all
right okay Gavin Bamber from North
Vancouver says please visit maybe maybe
not we'll see sure um I ask what is the
largest object in the
universe the universe the universe
itself the
universe no that's
a uh I'm guessing Gavin was looking for
a slightly different answer how come we
are are so unified in that ridiculous
joke I know we said that too many times
it depends I think it depends what they
mean by object like are we an object so
there forces that hold together our
right molecules but you can separate the
molecules right so what is the object
you or the molecules right right is the
Galaxy an object right even though it's
composed of
things that were stars and planet is you
know so on that scale what would you say
Charles well if I were to say that an
object is defined as something that is
being held together some recognizable
Way by some kind of force I go with that
okay then the largest objects are these
superclusters of galaxies out in space
they contain huge amounts of matter our
Milky weight you guys know has about
hundreds of billions of stars in it yeah
right but these superclusters contain
thousands sometimes hundreds of
thousands of galaxies and so you add all
that together and then there's all that
cosmological dark matter in between them
and so you've got a huge chunk of
material that all is bound together by
gravity so that would if it's bound if
it's bound together we think of that as
a coherent object yeah in that sense the
cluster as an object yes like what makes
it work Gravity Man got the gravity it's
me man gravity who you messing with what
you want to do okay so an illustrator is
going to come hear us and then have
gravity personify gravity it's going to
be Chuck's
voice all right that's all we got here
guys thanks for doing this once again
start talk special edition Neil degrass
Tyson here keep looking
[Music]
up